(audience applause)
- So, this is a real thing.
I didn't mean to stab
you with my fake nail.
I literally had one request this season.
I'm not kidding,
and it was, I really wanted...
There were two requests,
Alanis Morissette
and Teddy Swims.
- What a line up.
- It was my two...
I literally, I just wanted to meet you
'cause I'm such a fan and
I feel like I know you
'cause I've stalked you so much online.
And I just think you're incredible.
So thank you for being
here on our holiday show.
- Absolute privilege, I mean obviously,
giant fan as well.
- Whatever, you don't
have to be.
But wait do you get into Christmas?
We're celebrating the holidays.
Were you like the kid to
like unwrap your presents
and then wrap 'em back up?
- Yeah, actually there was a time
and my mom's probably gonna hear this now
and be very upset, but-
- I think parents know.
- Yeah.
Well we got away with it, so
remember when that Rock Band
game came out like forever ago?
We found out it was like
in this big, giant box
and was already wrapped
but he had found a way
that we could just peel the tape back
and we pulled all the
instruments out of it
and closed it back up,
and so it's just a big, empty box in there
completely taped shut,
and we played that game
for like three weeks
and she had no idea it ever happened,
and like the day before
we just slid it back in.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God.
- And so when she pulled it out,
"Oh my God, you got Rock Band for us!"
- This is crazy!
- No idea we'd already beaten
that game two weeks ago.
- First of all, you bring
it out, and they're like,
"They're prodigies! They're
playing it so well."
- We had already downloaded...
I mean, she probably saw credit card
receipts from where we'd
downloaded extra songs,
like I know she had to have known.
- I love that, you just
take the hair dryer
to release that tape,
kids, just so you know.
Take the hair dryer,
release it, slide it on off.
I actually never did it.
I'm pretty sure my older siblings did
but I never did it.
I don't know why.
I felt bad about it. I don't know.
I have a lot of fear (laughs).
- I gotta know everything
that someone's getting me.
There's no surprises.
- I am not curious at all
about things sometimes.
Yeah, I'm good with not knowing,
but how did you choose
the title of your album,
you know, "I've Tried
Everything But Therapy,
"Part One," but I just,
well one, I'm gonna ask you
have you ever really tried therapy?
But two, I kinda love that
it's the title of the album
because I feel like it is
therapeutic what we do naturally.
- Yeah, absolutely, I mean
it's therapeutic for me
in a lot of ways, but I think too
it was something where I wanted
to start the conversation
with myself 'cause I think like
this generation probably
is like the first people
that are like normalizing just
talking about mental health
at all and getting the
conversation going at all
because I feel like some
weird generational like
some mindset where it was like,
"I'm not going to therapy.
"I'm not crazy. I don't need
that," or, "I know what's
"wrong with me," you know,
and I feel like we just-
- Or in my world it was
like talk to your preacher.
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
- And it's like well that
can be helpful, definitely,
but like you know also,
people that are trained
in another version in another
way to give you tools.
- And so I think just having that,
and if I start that conversation
hopefully maybe it'll
inspire somebody else to
have that conversation
and go get the help and do
the work for themselves.
- Absolutely.
- I'm currently in the
process of talking to a couple
of people but also been
like in this place too where
it's doing what we do, too,
and on this rocket ship
that I'm kinda currently on,
I also want somebody to
kinda help me navigate that
and understand also what
I'm at and you know,
you gotta find the right person for you.
- Yeah, 'cause it does happen fast,
no matter how many years,
'cause it's not fast,
you've been doing it for a
bit, but when it does happen,
I do feel like it, it doesn't...
In anyone's career,
you could be hitting it
for like years and years and years,
but when it takes off, it takes off,
and it's alarming, it's jarring.
- Yeah and you're like oh no.
- Yeah, hold on.
- Here we go.
- Yeah and then everybody says
oh you gotta say yes to everything.
You never know when it's gonna stop.
And then you're worn out.
So by the way, take this advice,
it'll always be there
because your gift is there,
so people will always want to...
You know what I'm saying?
You have a God given
talent that is so rare,
like people always try and get you to say
yes to everything, say
yes to things you want to
say yes to, but like it is
important to also say no,
because you wear yourself out.
- Yeah we're working on
boundaries, yeah we sure are,
because I am not good at them.
- I don't think most artists are.
- I'm like, sure yeah.
- Sounds like a great plan.
And then meanwhile-
- I'm not tired at all.
- I'm a robot.
- Just keep the tequila going.
- And well that'll lead you
to another album, part two.
So explain your song, "Lose Control."
I love this song so much. It's so good.
- So I was in a relationship at a time
and me and this person were
kind of I think it got to
a point where the substance
of our relationship was
kind of the substances
we were abusing at the
time, you know, and our
high highs were just so
high and just so beautiful
and the lows were just
very awful and became
quite toxic and we became
very codependent on each other
and the things we were doing together
and the lifestyle we were living together
and no matter how much you love someone,
and you guys love each
other, sometimes you're just
bad for each other, you know, and
we were kind of just dragging each other
into just the pits of
hell basically, you know.
And we had to separate in order to like
for the best of both of us.
- For both of you, yeah.
- To heal and to understand
what was going on,
'cause I felt like we were just kind of
punishing each other
for what you do in life,
just punish each other for
trauma, that's not right.
- 'Cause you almost have to fix separately
and then come...
Yeah, yeah, you can't
put that on somebody.
- You can't be in charge
of somebody's happiness.
- It's hard enough being
in charge of your own.
(audience applause)
His debut album is out now.
It's called, "I Tried Everything
But Therapy, Part One."
It's 'cause you're too
young, you'll get there.
Speaking of therapy, it is the holidays
and Teddy and I are both
obsessed with the holidays.
Who isn't except for
Scrooge and the Grinch?
But what specifically do we
love about this time of year?
Well it's time to break it down
with a special edition of "Obsessions,"
this is Holiday Obsessions.
(audience applause)
That's a new one, that's a new one.
- I love this tune.
- All right, we love some tunes here.
That's right, it's time to
embrace our holiday obsessions.
I'm gonna hit this magical button
and the topic will be selected
by our super festive super computer,
'cause we are rich and have a huge budget.
Then the person obsessed
with the topic will own up
and sell everybody on it.
I have no idea what's gonna happen.
Anyway, let's go, I'm first. Here we go.
- What do we got here?
(Kelly laughs)
Gingerbread houses in bulk.
- My managers making fun of me.
I haven't seen these.
Okay, this just happened the other day.
My kids, we do gingerbread
houses, we build them every year,
but they come out with new ones
that are very exciting.
They have a tree house one this year,
they have a beach house,
and all these little...
So I buy a lot of them, Teddy.
I'm not even kidding.
- I just can't stand it.
- Oh my God, I love it.
- Ugh, sticky.
- Well I do it to where we can make a mess
and then you just like
pile it up in the bag
and then you tie it up and throw it away.
I do it in a smart way.
There's no glitter involved.
But no I love it, I get
tons of gingerbread houses
and we make them all.
Like nightly, during the
holidays, it's a lot.
I like crafts.
But I don't let them eat it.
They get really angry about that.
- But the candy's never
usually good on those things.
- They're children.
They will eat anything.
(Teddy laughs)
Yeah they will. I let
them eat it sometimes
but only on weekends.
They're garbage disposals.
I'm telling you.
Like my son will literally
pick it up off the ground,
I'm like, "All right, free probiotic."
Anyway, I'm obsessed with them.
I literally bought over 20.
Anyway, but we do them all.
It's all for a good cause,
for cheer.
Anyway, your turn. I'm crazy.
- All right let's see what happens now.
Rent, yes.
- Like paying rent or?
- Or no like Rent, the musical.
- Oh right, yeah.
- My senior year I got
to play in that show,
and I played Roger and my
best friend Jesse who's in my
band, he played Mark and
we were best buds in that.
I could play every character
from top to bottom.
I know every word to that whole show
and me and my moms watch
it every time I go home
for Christmas and we just
watch the Broadway version,
the DVD, we pull out the,
dust off the old DVD player
and everything, baby, it's my
favorite show in the world.
I'm so obsessed with it.
- This is how I know I'm
so much older than you.
I dust off a VHS, brother.
Just pop that puppy in.
- I was around for VHS.
I was around for VHS.
- I love that though, that's so special.
I love that musical, too.
- It's my Christmas like, you know,
my Christmas tradition with mom.
- Yeah. Okay everybody those were our
holiday obsessions.
(audience applause)
I like it, I like it.
I'm telling you the jingles
they go hard on the jingles.
It's very funny, usually
the other obsessions
is very sexy.
We kept it family for Christmas.
Teddy (laughs).
Teddy and I are performing
his song, "Lose Control,"
later in the show so stick around
for my favorite moment this year.
His debut album is called,
"I've Tried Everything
But Therapy, Part One."
You've gotta get it. It's so great, y'all.
We'll be right back with
some holiday gift ideas.
(audience applause)